if there is
anything that needs to be satirized and
remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way
extra points if you can sample trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
big massive dumps
[Music]
big massive
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the
[Music]
[Music]
as opposed to once
[Music]
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost of the election
what is going on here what is going what
is going on
here it's just beyond parody
massive dumps cost them the election
what is going on here what is going on
[Music]
[Music]
all right let's cut it just because
there's so much to talk about and it's
really uh it's really a big day it's
it's almost a year to the day
since donald trump announced what is
sort of the informal start to
the quarantine now you know a lot of
people didn't do it
a lot of people never wore a mask or did
anything but we are getting almost to
the year point
and it is unbelievable what we have gone
through through the last
year and joe biden expecting to sort of
catch everybody up
on what it is that's going on and what's
going to be going on moving forward and
and just a ton of stuff has been going
on joe biden signed into law today
the third coveted relief bill many of
you will be getting cash
soon uh we also yesterday got the
announcement from joe biden
that 100 million additional johnson
johnson doses uh will be have been will
be acquired
by the united states and um
we have cases fortunately starting to
continuing to trickle down let's look at
the latest data today
uh okay actually so today trickling up a
little bit
um unfortunately but still a curve of
improvement as you can see that's cases
here is
deaths so those continuing to go down
and it makes sense that at a certain
point the the death decline
curve would be steeper than cases
because you will have the most at-risk
people
overall getting vaccinated first and
you'll also have a lot of young people
just going buck wild getting the virus
but not
dying so that's going on there we also
have
from the standpoint of vaccine doses a
lot a lot a lot going on
let me get the latest numbers a really
strong day today
just shy of 2.5 million new doses the
two
of the seven day average now 2.23
million
i do like to see how many of those are
the jnj
yesterday it was about 460 000 let's
find
the vax oh i'm not seeing it they had
that yesterday
uh where did that go oh oh wait a second
no hold on
you have to go to the cdc this is all
based on cdc data
so let's go to the
underlying vaccinations here it is
um vaccinations it was on this page how
many jnjs okay
638 000 all right so that's ramping up
the janssen vaccine as i uh
and dr fauci like to call it is uh we
are seeing acceleration there so there's
a lot of really good things going on
and so we're going to be hearing from
joe biden momentarily
i would love to be forced to open the
phone lines tonight i'm even debating
going twitch exclusive on phone lines
it's the rare nighttime stream we
haven't had one in a little while
so if people want phone lines open we
have a goal of 100 website members and
twitch subs
i may even go twitch exclusive just to
throw together
three or four different meaningless and
arbitrary
elements so that's going on and uh to
that end
let me thank some people techolote just
signed up via twitch
remy bucky signed up stony wankin
boy just signed up who else
astro lycos gifted five so that's
putting us at eight
and then tekolote gifted a ninth sub
so zero plus nine is where we are and
that math
every one of us can feel very very good
about zero plus nine is nine
i also wanna read a super chat that just
came in cockeyed rooster says david
would you consider debunking ted
cruz's claims that coveted relief is
only 10 for americans i've heard a lot
of my conservative friends bring it up
you know what cockeyed just for you i
will include
that debunking tomorrow on the friday
podcast
just because you asked for it now the
truth is
i've already recorded that segment and i
already planned to include it on
tomorrow's show
but let's pretend that's not the case
that is a request
i will absolutely um uh
uh placate or acquiesce to
all right so that'll be on tomorrow's
program in all seriousness that will be
on
tomorrow's program it's a really dumb
talking point really really dumb talking
point okay
so that'll be tomorrow also want to say
thanks to hat mumfree
for the twitch sub appreciate that
that's number 10
and we are wide open on the website a
coupon code better 21
works perfectly for membership discounts
of
all kinds so i i have a lot of different
things actually to look at today maybe
i'll just start going in order
let's just dive right in why not okay
anthony fauci
us could reach pre-pandemic normals by
september
things are starting to look more and
more optimistic
top infectious disease expert dr anthony
fauci
or as some of my callers call him falci
said wednesday that current vaccination
levels indicate the u.s could reach
pre-pandemic levels of normal life by
late august or early september
supposed to be at a wedding in italy on
september 1.
will it happen i don't know
fauci made the comment during a virtual
news briefing fauci says their best
estimates regarding herd immunity
is around 70 to 85 percent of the
population
at current rates that should be reached
by the end of the north american
summer but he also said if the nation is
vaccinating two to three million a day
society is increasingly more protective
you don't have to wait until you get
full heard
to get a really profound effect on what
you can do that's absolutely right
as you all know earlier this week we
heard from the cdc
vaccinated people can hang out together
indoors without masks
and some other additional elements were
also cleared by the cdc
additional good news we continue to hear
we don't yet
know if the vaccine prevents
asymptomatic infections
we are much closer to knowing the pfizer
covid vaccine moderna works almost
identically and is believed to be
similar
pfizer covet vaccine blocks 94
of asymptomatic infections
and 97 oh hold on a second i got to drop
a banhammer
okay someone got it thanks guys wow the
moderator's even even
faster than me on that uh blocks 94 of
asymptomatic and 97
of symptomatic cases in israeli study
really really strong data and believed
to dramatically reduce transmission
obviously if you don't get sick at all
symptomatic or asymptomatic there's
nothing for you to transmit
really good data really really good data
and i see that we have a lot of
immunologists and epidemiologists here
who disagree with
pfizer the israeli health ministry dr
fauci rachel wolenski they
there's people it's crazy the people in
my chat know more than all these doctors
i'm really blessed to have such a um
brilliant brilliant
audience okay um a couple of other
things but just a moment here
uh peppy asks do you feel safe for
having both vaccines
i do i really do no doubt about
it uh no doubt about it whatsoever
i want to say thanks to katherine
cunningham
who just signed up at joinedpakman.com
and is kicking us off
on what is um a painting to be a night
on which we open phone lines which would
be great
also want to say thanks to james lester
james lester is new member number 12
today james perfectly entering the
coupon code better21
on my website also want to say thanks to
less
on on for the twitch
sub thanklesscontroller has gifted one
marzipaz just signed up shel
marie gwillgomm
kaylee that's six more wow
exciting thanks everybody very much
appreciate that
oh and sorry i also want to say thanks
to a a
a a signing up at joinpakman.com as well
okay more news today we have updated
information on who is least likely to
get vaccinated
i think most of you probably would be
able to guess
um let's look at some data from the
latest npr pbs news
marist poll do you approve or disapprove
of how biden is handling the pandemic
somewhere
right around 62 percent approve in a
country this polarized that is
significant
next bit of data
if this is where i wanted to go if maybe
i can even
no okay it's not an image if a vaccine
for the coronavirus is made available to
you will you choose to be vaccinated
overall now only 30 don't plan to be
vaccinated
22 have already received at least one
dose
45 percent plan to 30 say no
that's a problem okay that's a problem
the most anti-vax groups are
republican men half of whom don't plan
to get a vaccine
those who supported trump in 2020 47
of whom planned not to get vaccinated
white men or i'm sorry
white men without college degrees 40
say no vax for me white evangelical
christians 38
say no dice those under 45 37
say no vaccine 37 latino
36 rural or rural as some say
36 percent of independence 28 of whites
and 25
of blacks say no vaccine
this is an interesting reversal so
there's there's kind of overlapping data
um it is it is generally believed that
uh black americans lean more
anti-vaccine
because so many uh
white people are evangelical christians
which are very anti-vax it also puts
white
folks in here by sheer numbers uh and so
you almost need like venn diagrams to
really look at this data
uh cross-sectionally so to speak so
that's interesting let me see was there
anything else
no nothing else okay so that's
everything i wanted to look at
there bidets r us wants to know david
are you satisfied with your current
bidet system use the coupon code
meme for 20 off our entire stock we love
you son you know what i was thinking of
getting
uh hold on i saw one of these today
with built in bidet i am looking
really strongly at uh
make making some plumbing purchases
and this has come highly recommended
this is the
toto washlet elongated
integral integrated dual flush toilet
and bidet seating cotton white
by the way what does dual flush mean
does that mean it flushes twice i don't
know
this thing is pretty high tech and
supposedly this is also
um highly highly energy efficient
so i'm looking at a couple of these
really strongly now what is this other
item
it's like a control panel of some kind
wow
that's nuts for two grand they'd better
give you free shipping can you imagine
yeah i'm gonna pay for shipping on that
all right so anyway uh
are plumbers in the audience the thing
is even with double flush under biden
we're expecting to have to flush 10 to
15 times i don't even know if dual flush
is enough
is there a new plan to get a 15 minimum
wage yet not that i'm aware of
alex cunningham says been watching your
show for a while i've learned a lot you
make my day better because i'm gaining
knowledge instead of letting my brain
melt with alternative facts
keep up the good work people asking what
i'm reading
okay i have two new book recommendations
for you guys i am reading
um a james i've not read any james
baldwin somehow i've gotten this
this uh far in life without ever reading
james baldwin i am reading james
baldwin's novel
giovanni's room um
and i am also reading the second of
three books
in the mars trilogy by kim stanley
robinson
green mars both eminently enjoyable
eminently enjoyable
um okay do you guys
want do you guys
want a vote on troy york voicemails or
unban adjudications let me know in the
meantime i need to thank a few more
people
big thank you to jerry henson for
signing up at joinedpakman.com
andrew bursitt has just signed up at
joinedpakman.com
dwayne robertson has just signed up at
joinpacman.com matthew
mina new member number four ryan
rostkowski
new member number five samuel benton new
member number six and robert suarez is
number seven
nineteen plus seven seven plus nine is
sixteen six carry the one one plus one
is two
puts us at twenty six and then also
thank you to i'm inconsolable
18 months 18 months
subscribed at tier 3.
i'm inconsolable very strong also
thankless controller has just gifted ten
shot x thomas signed up that's 12
shell marie gifting one is thirteen
chris houlihan
is number fourteen fourteen plus twenty
six
six plus four is zero carry the one two
plus one plus one is four
that's forty guys that is 40. all right
let's go through
let's do the unban requests first i have
three unban requests twitch has a
mechanism where if you get banned by one
of our moderators
you can request an unban i got a
gavel by popular demand uh
and so i am calling this court of unbans
to order
there it is first one a user who goes by
the handle
virus untreated yesterday
said no one here can prove that covet 19
even exists they were banned
for spreading covet disinformation their
unban request
is you is free speech send sword
cutting out a man's tomb does not prove
he is a liar
you just prove you are scared of what he
has to say
this ban unban request is hereby
denied and you are sentenced to
permanent
ban that one is an easy one
next user goes by the name ice hockey
here are some of their messages you
radical liberals
act like the phone call is a big deal he
is explaining the fraud auditor's
fund don't know what that means the
world
loves trump oh this is from
from january 4th i'll be in dc
on january 6th to fight for my president
donald j
trump this may be a rioter that's not
even why they were banned
they then said we want trump back bring
back trump biden lied
dems through foreign aid in the bill we
don't need 20 million going to pakistan
for gender studies
a man is a man and a woman is a woman
bring
trump back they were banned by our
moderator travis
mccostler their unban request is are you
banning liberals or just conservatives
no we are banning rioters this uh
unbanned request is hereby
denied and made permanent
and then we have just one more here
this is a user who goes by the name big
papa
uh they were banned today oh just a
little while ago
hello from michigan f all politicians
politicians or puppets entitled no
entitled elitists can shine their own
shoes get your head out of your ass
has anyone heard of a reverse exorcism
pi is a new digital currency developed
by stanford phds
they posted a referral link okay david's
snorting lines
happy international women's day i'll get
the goddamn
laundry done hi i'm david pakman please
watch me regurgitate propaganda they
were banned
their unban request is i promise i won't
be such an [ __ ] anymore
um it that is uh that is just too
weaponized that is hereby
denied and you have been permanently
banned
and we can now go back to regular order
having adjudicated all
pending unban requests
okay let's go next to whether people
want me to play
new troy york voicemails troy york has
gotten
really really pedantic and so we've not
been playing his voicemails
but i do have a couple new ones he's
trying to be more interesting
i will leave it up to people in the chat
to tell me whether they want me to play
them
uh you can vote now i've pasted a link
to the poll
in twitch as well as in youtube and
it'll take just a moment
for the votes to tally in the meantime
let's look at some super chats where did
i leave off
um
will midweek politics with david pakman
be back no that's the old name of the
show like a decade ago it's gone
had a bad 2020 and that time i got the
vaccine and i'm back working is 2021
looking better than last year for you
david yeah
2021's looking better from many
standpoints no doubt about it
david i'm already a member but with an
illegally ridiculous discount i want to
support the channel without the discount
should i cancel and re-up legally yes
that's exactly right
that's exactly right i don't know why we
still have no
results here we've been having this
issue with straw poll lately where the
results just like don't show up for a
while have people been voting i'll put
the links
in the chat again putting it in twitch
and in youtube um
it might be broken i don't know i just
refreshed it still still says zero
zero let's see if they tally in a moment
ah there we go 5743 people declining
troy york voicemails that's fair
that if people don't want them i won't
play them
williams says if biden could pass a
voting stimulus i believe most people
would vote left and republicans would
never win what are your thoughts
uh i'd have to see what you mean by a
voting stimulus
any chance you'll do alive with producer
pat sometime maybe
anything's on the table david pakman
worried about shipping while interested
in buying a two thousand dollar toilet
gotta love it i'm not really buying that
toilet guys i'm kidding around
my mom is a leftist on policy but is
always on the wrong side of the culture
war pro seuss auntie markle how do i
talk to her
i don't know that's that's tough
watching your show brings me happiness
much information and laughs remind us
again how we can use our free
prime twitch sub to benefit you okay
listen to what i've heard
someone told me that 90 of amazon prime
subscribers in twitch chat don't know
that for free they can subscribe to my
channel with twitch prime and take money
from bezos and give it to me
people don't even realize this so we're
not doing troll york
voicemails it's clearly a no so the
knows have it
no troy york voicemails congratulations
to everybody on that
standing by for joe biden uh yes
if you are if you have amazon prime
and you don't know about twitch prime
you have five dollars you can take from
bezos and send to me right now
all you have to do is connect amazon
prime to twitch prime
google it if you don't know how very
simple very very simple
okay i have a total washlet it's amazing
recommend the one that heats the water
got a cheaper one for my second bath not
as good
good to know when will biden reveal a
build green better deal to address the
climate crisis in green energy i hope
very soon
high high priority
donna williams says please address the
fool saying biden is senile not true
thank you david
i don't think he's senile i think he's
he's slowed down from where he was and
he has a stutter i don't think he's
senile
amy medina has just signed up at
joinedpakman.com
thank you amy chris nichols has just
signed up at joinpackman.com
thank you chris and a whole bunch of
people on twitch to thank let me see
here
lazco little blue doggy flash points is
three
gooner is four commodore chomp is five
hey it's wyatt is six ten beers deep is
seven
saves america is eight captain flash
heart
is nine mahaffey taffy is ten
doom pickle is eleven
um oh eleven okay good
puts us at 53 and just a reminder
because it's the rare evening stream
we are looking at opening phones and
maybe even going twitch exclusive
for the phone lines uh we have a goal of
100
website members and twitch subs we are
53
of the way there 53 of the way there
which is
really incredible um
oh wow a whole bunch of other people
himalayan salty just subbed bluffing
with my muffin fish
of the day and archer bird that's
another four
massive dumps of memberships yeah
kimberly go
number 58 um all right
let me step away from that just because
i do want to get to other messages
has gensake yet made thee i'll never lie
to you promise she i don't believe she's
made that promise
bidet biden washes away the vote the
vote dumps
well said can't wait to watch all the
bonus shows i've missed doing that
tomorrow also i love the gavel it's a
nice touch to the live streams yeah it's
not a bad it's a little cartoonish
but i like it mr nobody says i no longer
refer to biden by name when i talk about
him i say
father and look up that's a little too
too cultish for me david the family is
watching give a shout out to christy
addie and logan
absolutely here is joe biden
let's make sure we're muted elsewhere
let's take a listen
good evening my fellow americans big
announcement delight
i'd like to talk to you about where we
are as we mark
one year since everything stopped
because of this pandemic
a year ago were hit with a virus
that was met with silence and spread
unchecked
denials for days weeks then months
that led to more deaths strong stars
infections
more stress and more loneliness
photos and videos from 2019
feel like they were taken in another era
the last vacation well said last
birthday with friends
the last holiday with extended family
while it was different for everyone we
all lost something
a collective suffering a collective
sacrifice
a year filled with the loss of life
and the loss of living for all of us
but in the loss we saw how much there
was to gain
in appreciation respect and gratitude
finding light in the darkness is a very
american thing to do in fact
it may be the most american thing we do
and that's what we've done we've seen
frontline and essential workers risking
their lives sometimes losing them
to save and help others researchers and
scientists
racing for a vaccine and
so many of you as hemingway wrote
being strong in all the broken places
trump prefers dostoyevsky i know it's
been hard
i truly know as i've told you before
i carry a card in my pocket with the
number of americans
who have died from covert to date it's
on the back of my schedule
as of now total deaths in america
527
726.
that's more deaths than in world war one
world war ii the vietnam war
and 9 11 combined there were husbands
wives sons and daughters grandparents
friends neighbors
young and old they leave behind loved
ones
unable to truly grieve or to heal even
to have a funeral
but i'm also thinking about everyone
else who lost this past year
to natural causes by cruel fate of
accident or other disease
they too died alone they too leave
behind
loved ones who are hurting badly
you know you've often heard me say
before i talk about the longest walk
any parent can make is up a short flight
of stairs to his child's bedroom
to say i'm sorry i lost my job
i can't be here anymore like my dad told
me
when he lost his job in scranton
so many of you had to make that same
walk this past year
you lost your job you closed your
business
facing eviction homelessness hunger
a loss of control maybe worst of all a
loss of hope
watching a generation of children who
may be set back up to a year or more
because they've not been in school
because of their loss of learning
it's the details of life that matter the
most
and we miss those details the big
details on the small moments
weddings birthdays graduations
all the things that needed to happen but
didn't
the first date the family reunions
the sunday night rituals it's all
has exacted a terrible cost on the
psyche of so many of us
for we are fundamentally a people who
want to be
with others to talk to laugh
to hug to hold one another
but this virus has kept us apart and
grandparents haven't seen their children
or grandchildren
parents haven't seen their kids
kids haven't seen their friends the
things we used to do
that always filled us with joy had
become things
we couldn't do and broke our hearts
too often we've turned against one
another
a mask the easiest thing to do to save
lives
sometimes it divides us states
pitted against one another instead of
working with each other
vicious hate crimes against asian
americans
who've been attacked harassed blamed and
scapegoated
at this very moment so many of them
are fellow americans they're on the
front lines of this pandemic trying to
save lives
and still still they're forced to live
in fear
for their lives just walking down
streets in america
it's wrong it's un-american and it
must stop
look we know what we need to do to beat
this virus
tell the truth follow the scientists
the science work together put trust and
faith in our government to fulfill its
most important function which is
protecting the american people no
function more important
we need to remember the government isn't
some foreign force in a distant capital
no it's us all of us we the people
for you and i that america thrives
when we give our hearts when we turn
our hands to common purpose
and right now my friends we're doing
just that
and i have to say as your president i'm
grateful to you
last summer i was in philadelphia and i
met a
small business owner a woman i asked her
i said
what do you need most never forget what
she said to me
she said looking behind the eyes she
said i
just want the truth the truth
just tell me the truth
think of that my fellow americans
you wrote nothing less than the truth
and for all of you asking when things
will get back to normal
here is the truth let's see the only way
to get our lives back
to get our economy back on track is to
beat the virus you've been hearing me
say that for while i was running and the
last
50 days i've been president but this is
one of the most
complex operations we've under ever
undertaken as a nation in a long time
that's why i'm using every power i have
as president of the united states
to put us on a war footing to get the
job done
sounds like hyperbole but i mean it a
war footing
and thank god we're making some real
progress now
and my first full day in office i
outline for you
a comprehensive strategy to beat this
pandemic
we've spent every day since attempting
to carry it out
two months ago a country this country
didn't have nearly enough vaccine supply
to vaccinate
all or ever near all of the american
public
but soon we will we've been working with
vaccine manufacturers
pfizer moderna johnson and johnson to
manufacture and purchase hundreds of
millions of doses
of these three safe effective vaccines
and now at the direction and with the
assistance of my administration
johnson and johnson is working together
with a competitor
merck to speed up and increase the
capacity
to manufacture new johnson and johnson
vaccine which is one shot
in fact just yesterday i announced
and i met with the ceos of both
companies i announced
our plan to buy an additional 100
million doses
of johnson and johnson vaccines
these two companies competitors have
come together for the good of the nation
and they should be applauded for it
it's truly a national effort just like
we saw during world war
ii now because all the work we've done
we'll have enough vaccine supply for all
adults in america by the end of may
stunning that's months ahead of schedule
and we're mobilizing thousands of
vaccinators to put the vaccine in one's
arm
calling active duty military fema
retired doctors and nurses
administrators done it 24-7
and those to administer the shots
and we've been creating more places to
get the shots
we've made it possible for you to get a
vaccine at nearly
one any one of ten thousand pharmacies
across the country
just like you get your flu shot we're
also working with governors and mayors
in red states and blue states to set up
and support nearly
600 federally supported vaccination
centers
that administers hundreds of thousands
of shots
per day you can drive up to a stadium or
a large parking lot
get your shot never leave your car and
drive home in less than an hour
been sending that to hundreds of
community health centers
all across america located in
underserved areas
and we've been deploying and we will
deploy more mobile vehicles and pop-up
clinics
to meet you where you live so those who
are least able to get the vaccine are
able to get it
we continue to work on making at home
testing available
and we've been focused on serving people
in the hardest hit communities of this
pandemic
black latino native american and rural
communities
so what does all this add up to when i
took office 50 days ago
only 8 percent of the americans after
months
only eight percent of those over the age
of 65 have gotten their first
vaccination
today that number is 65 percent
that's a number just 14 of americans
over the age of 75 50 50 days ago had
gotten their first shot
today that number is well over 70
percent
with new guidance from the centers for
disease control and prevention
the cdc that came out on monday
it means simply this millions and
millions of grandparents
who went months without being able to
hug their grandkids
can now do so and the more people are
fully vaccinated
the cd will continue to provide
additional guidance
on what you can do in the workplace
places of worship with your friends
as well as travel right
when i came into office you may recall i
set a goal that many of you said was
that kind of
way over the top i said it wasn't an
ambition i said i intended to get a
hundred million shots in people's arms
in my first hundred days in office
tonight i can say we're not only going
to meet that goal we're going to crush
it we're going to beat that goal easily
because we're actually on track to reach
this goal of 100 million shots and arms
on my 60th day in office
no other country in the world has done
this
none i want to talk about the next steps
we're thinking about here we go
first tonight i'm announcing that i will
direct all states
tribes and territories to make all
adults
people 18 and over eligible to be
vaccinated
no later than may 1. wow
all adult americans will be eligible to
get a vaccine
no later than may 1.
that's much earlier than expected let me
be clear
you better have the doses for it you're
going to have that shot immediately
better have the doses for it get in line
beginning may 1.
every adult will eligible to get their
shot and to do this
we're going to go from a million shots a
day that i promised in december here we
go
before i was sworn in to maintaining
beating our current pace of 2 million
shots a day
outpacing the rest of the world wow
secondly
wow at the time when every adult is
eligible in may
may one we will launch with our partners
new tools to make it easier for you to
find the vaccine and where to get the
shot
beautiful including a new website that
will help you first find the place
to get vaccinated and the one nearest
you this is what we need
no more searching day and night five
websites
for you and your loved ones thirdly
with the passage of the american rescue
plan and i thank again the house and
senate for passing it
and my announcement last month of a plan
to vaccinate teachers and school staff
including bus drivers we can accelerate
massive nationwide effort to reopen our
schools
safely and meet my goal that i stated at
the same time about 100 million shots
of opening majority of k-8 schools
in my first hundred days in office this
is going to be the number one priority
of my new secretary of education
miguel cardona fourth
in the coming weeks we will issue
further guidance
on what you can and cannot do once fully
vaccinated right
to lessen the confusion to keep people
safe
and encourage more people to get
vaccinated let's keep it going
and finally fifth and maybe most
importantly
i promise i will do everything in my
power
i will not relent until we beat this
virus
but i need you the american people i
need you
i need every american to do their part
that's not hyperbole i need you i need
you to get vaccinated when it's your
turn and when you can find an
opportunity
and to help your family your friends
your neighbors
get vaccinated as well because here's
the point
if we do all this if we do our part
if we do this together by july the 4th
there's a good chance you your families
and friends
right we'll be able to get together in
your backyard or in your neighborhood
and have a cookout at a barbecue and
celebrate independence day can you
imagine that doesn't mean
large events with lots of people
together but it does mean
small groups will be able to get
together after this long hard year
that will make this independence day
something truly special
where we not only mark our independence
as a nation
but we begin to mark our independence
from this virus
wow but to get there
we can't let our guard down this fight
is far from order
from over as i told the woman in
pennsylvania i'll tell you the truth
a july 4th with your loved ones
is the goal but a goal
a lot can happen i still think we should
go for easter of last year like trump
said
scientists have made clear that things
may get worse again
as new variants of the virus spread
we've got work to do to ensure that
everyone has confidence in
the safety and effectiveness of all
three vaccines
so my message to you is this listen to
dr fauci
one of the most distinguished and
trusted voices in the world right
he's assured us the vaccines are safe
they underwent rigorous scientific
review
i know they're safe vice president haran
harris and i know they're safe that's
why we got the vaccine
publicly in front of cameras so for the
world to see
so you could see us do it
the first lady the second gentleman also
got vaccinated
talk to your family friends your
neighbors the people you know best
who've gotten the vaccine
we need everyone to get vaccinated
we need everyone to keep washing their
hands
stay socially distanced and keep wearing
the mask
as recommended by the cdc
because even if we devote every resource
we have
beating this virus and getting back to
normal depends on
national unity and national unity isn't
just how politics and politicians vote
in washington
what the loudest voices say in cable or
online
unity is what we do together as fellow
americans because we don't stay vigilant
and the conditions change then we may
have to reinstate restrictions
to get back on track not a party unless
we make it one
again we've made so much progress
this is not the time to let up just as
we were emerging from a dark winter
into a hopeful spring and summer is not
the time
to not stick with the rules
i'll close with this we've lost so much
over the last year we've lost family
and friends we've lost businesses
and dreams we spent years building
we've lost time time with each other and
our children have lost so much time with
their friends
time with their schools no graduation
ceremonies just
this spring no graduations from college
high school
moving up ceremonies you know
there's something else we lost we lost
faith
in whether our government and our
democracy can deliver on really hard
things
right for the american people couldn't
under trump but as i stand here tonight
we're proving once again something i've
said time and time again to the
probably tired of hearing me say it i
say it to foreign leaders and domestic
alike
it's never ever a good bet to bet
against the american people
america is coming back
the development manufacturing
distribution of vaccines and record time
is a true miracle of science
it's one of the most extraordinary
achievements any country has ever
accomplished
we also just saw the perseverance rover
land on mars
stunning images of our dreams that are
now
reality another example of the
extraordinary american ingenuity
commitment and belief in science
and one another and today
i signed into law the american rescue
plan
cash an historic piece of legislation
for membership
delivers immediate relief to millions of
people
includes 1 400 in direct rescue checks
payments that means a typical family of
four earning about
and ten thousand dollars will get checks
for five thousand
six hundred dollars deposited if they
have direct deposit
or in a check a treasury check
it extends unemployment benefits it
helps small businesses
lowers health care premiums for many it
provides
food and nutrition keeps families in
their homes
and will cut child poverty in this
country in half
according to the experts and a fine
and it funds all the steps i've just
described
to beat the virus and create millions of
jobs
in the coming weeks and months i'll be
traveling along with the first lady the
vice president the second gentleman
members of my
cabinet to speak directly to you to tell
you the truth
about how the american rescue plan meets
the moment
starting the rally sales at any page i
will acknowledge that it failed
but it will not about how after
long dark years one whole year
there is hope and light of better days
ahead
if we all do our part this country will
be vaccinated soon
our economy will be on the mend our kids
will be back in school
and we'll have proven once again
that this country can do anything hard
things
big things important things
over a year ago no one could have
imagined
what we were about to go through in more
ways than one but now we're coming
through it
and it's a shared experience that binds
us together as a nation
we are bound together by the loss and
the pain of the days
that have gone by but also bound
together by the hope
and the possibilities of the days in
front of us
my fervent prayer for our country is
that after all we've been through
we'll come together as one people
one nation one america
i believe we can and we will
we're seizing this moment in history i
believe will record
we faced and overcame one of the
toughest and darkest periods in this
nation's history
darkest we've ever known i promise you
we'll come out stronger with a renewed
faith in ourselves
a renewed commitment to one another to
our communities and to our country
this is the united states of america
and there's nothing nothing from the
bottom of my heart i believe this
there's
nothing we can't do when we do it
together
so god bless you all and please
god give solace to all those people who
lost someone
and may god protect our troops thank you
for taking the time to listen
i look forward to seeing you
major major news made by president joe
biden
uh i am not like the biggest biden fan
this is not about the minimum wage this
is not about anything other than whoever
wrote this speech deserves a raise
this was uh arguably the best thing
biden has done
could not be more different i mean no
question whatsoever
could not be more different than what we
got from trump a year ago
and what we continued to get for from
trump the big news
joe biden if you've been wondering when
will i be eligible
not me i know you guys aren't worried
about when i will be eligible
when will you be eligible when would one
be eligible
joe biden apparently believes that we
will have the supply
for uh every state
to open vaccination to 18 plus
no later than may 1st
now how quickly everyone will be able to
get an appointment
depends on coveted money getting to get
more vaccinator sites going
we got to be running them 24 7. uh but
absolutely um a well well-delivered
speech
i would let let's go to phone calls very
soon we're almost there we are at 81 out
of a hundred
if you're just joining us and wondering
who am i that's a great question
uh but the best way to get the phone
lines open get a membership at
joinpackman.com i feel we are close
ellen polikowski just signed up
putting us at 82 so we're really close
here
okay join pacman.com the coupon code
it's such a big discount it's illegal i
won't even tell you how big of a
discount it is
if you're on twitch you can use your
twitch prime sub or whatever it is that
you want it all
counts okay it all counts
very very exciting stuff
and uh let me look at some super chats
here
so many people the department of va is
starting to open vaccinations to
caregivers unenrolled vets families
beautiful rebecca sending a five dollar
super chat in honor of biden's integrity
poke says this is boring he hasn't
blamed his predecessor or insulted the
media even once beta
he also didn't use any xenophobic terms
i mean
notably absent from this speech was a
reference to the china virus
uh it's it's a new time nomadic hippie
says i'm trying to get the vaccine as a
truck driver it's hard to make
appointments
i feel like if i was trucking i would
actually look along my
route and see where might i be able to
get it of course only if that's legal i
don't know if you're a resident of one
state if you can get it in a different
state
that is all those are those are all good
questions good questions
but ones that we hopefully will will get
answers to
david in a family of five i'm the only
one getting the vaccine my sister-in-law
two nieces aren't getting it let's say
if they find out i got it it won't be
pleasant
wow people would be mad at you charles
if they knew you got the vaccine
it's sad biden has to beg americans to
have common sense and get vaccinated
trump was a buffoon
he caused others to disagree with
science i know
doo doo bean says i don't know i felt
more informed when trump kept saying
we're rounding the curve
every other week zachary says things to
remember
biden is under-promising and
over-delivering we certainly will have
more than small gatherings by the fourth
if all goes well
i believe he is under-promising and
over-delivering that's exactly right
they were already doing a million
vaccines before this clown was in office
wrong they were doing 890 000 a day and
at the time that he made the promise
they were only doing 600 000 a day but
don't let facts get in the way of an
aggressive
super chat we are not broken truth wins
how did an inquisitive guy like rogan
become a kova denialist yeah i haven't
seen the clip yet but i need to take a
look at what joe rogan has been saying
about the vaccine
good parley says david you're the total
package thanks for the years of content
thank you
cockeyed rooster says i think you're one
of the best progressive voices on the
left objective and pragmatic
god a membership will continue to
support your work
bring jessie lee peterson back beta
that's ugly is this what it feels like
to have a president again i guess so
cody says i'm glad biden is doing well
for covet in the u.s but what about your
obligations to send the vaccine we paid
for to canada we've been left behind
i don't know enough about that to say to
say what's going on
um okay i want to say
thank you to brandon petruska
as well as miguel good pasture
new members 83 and 84
and then an explosive explosive donation
of subs on twitch ky dizzle just
gifted five inconsolable gifted 18
now the top gifter on the channel with
something like 540.
my brother-in-law first removed by
domestic partnership be coldy has just
re-upped his
sub let me see here 15 43
that's plus 25 84 plus 25.
five plus four is nine eight plus two is
zero carry the one
we are at 109 we are at 109
and we did it folks we did it let's get
those phone lines
open oh my god have i been muted the
last hour have i been streaming muted
this entire time
come on guys that it's we should almost
i i want to talk to the moderators
should we ban
for people who do the your muted
trolling
is that is that bandworthy
that's something to think about thanks
to matthew monroe
as well as tracy mcreight new members
number 110 and 111
all right let's get to some calls i want
to hear from you we finally did it
davidpakman.com is the place let me
unmute for phone calls
but yeah i want to hear from you guys
and in really really incredible
announcements from
joseph r biden jr tonight
a lot a lot of things going on
by the big news joe biden directing
governors of all 50 states
make all adults eligible by may 1. now
by the way someone in the chat
wanted to bet me 12 grand they'd get
vaccinated before me
i'm fully vaccinated so let me know if
you could want to pay via paypal
or if you want to do 12 000 in subs or
how you want to do that but that is a
that is a bet
uh taken and won my friend i hope that
that was for real
okay if you want to ch yeah then i'll
take venmo whatever people want
davidpakman.com discord
is the place to get on you can get into
the waiting lobby and we are going to
chat with some people
i will continue to thank various folks
who sign up in fact we just got
10 more twitch subs just dropping out of
nowhere
oh don't even know where those came from
all right let's see let's hear from some
people let's go to
who do we have there's just a lot going
on
let's go to river from chicago
river from chicago you're on the air uh
have you ever came here i can hear you
loud and clear
hey how are you doing well all right
um so first time caller uh
long-time listener oh just gotta wanna
know your thoughts about uh see seems on
the on the right
a lot of people are on the right as i
said
they are sort of trying to
spin this uh the vaccine that is and try
to give trump credit for the vaccine
right um and it just doesn't i don't
know i
just doesn't seem like they have that's
there you know it seems like uh
from what i recall trump was um he
wasn't even ordering enough vaccines and
didn't even have a plan at all
yeah that's true i mean listen what we
can say about trump is
he certainly didn't stand in the way
like trump wants credit for things any
sane president would do like trump wants
credit
trump kept repeating you know the thing
we're doing
we're investing in vaccine production
even before we have the results of the
phase three trials it's like yeah that's
done all the time you start pretty
when when you have an urgent situation
governments that are functioning
start producing vaccines even before you
know for sure like
any pre the things trump did any
president would have done
but trump failed on a lot he failed on
testing the vaccine rollout was so slow
he
last july he was offered 100 million
more doses from
pfizer and he said no biden had to clean
that up
so yeah i mean you know trump didn't
stand in the way but he certainly didn't
do much to help
right right and i mean all the
misinformation that he
was also pedaling on twitter and whatnot
of course
all that stuff definitely obviously
wasn't helping so yeah
um speaking of twitter how do you feel
about uh his
twitter being reinstated well it hasn't
been as far as i know i mean he started
he's starting he wrote letters and they
were republished to twitter but
has he actually been put back on twitter
i didn't think he was uh
i saw people chatting i guess it was
just rumors that it's back up i don't
have twitter so i thought oh no no no i
i have a clip about that if people want
to check that out i have a clip called
trump forces his way back on twitter but
what he's doing is he's writing
statements and then
don jr is posting the image of the
statements it's really pathetic actually
yeah it seems like he would be using
people he knew by proxy exactly
just though you know his attention
seeking self well anyway david that's
all i have
all right river from chicago thank you
very much appreciate the call
uh i do want to say thank you to taylor
crippa
who just signed up at joinpakman.com
taylor
using the coupon code better21 and using
it perfectly
also want to say thanks to thankless
controller kelly beach and margot
cabot for signing up via twitch and
twitch prime and related twitch
subscriptions
let's talk next via discord to
let's go to kyoko from japan what is it
there
9 30 in the morning hi
hello hello hi you're on the air yes i
can hear you
okay well you know what i think i have
to connect
to my earphone because i can't hear your
voice very well
by all means make to the earphone that's
fine are you is it 9 30 in the morning
there
uh it's 10 30. 10 30 in the morning oh
my god
oh right 14 hours okay that makes sense
right
wow i've been a big fan of yours for
years
thank you yeah it's it's great i mean
wow it's so exciting i'm pretty sure
you're our first japanese caller kyoko
oh really yeah wow it's so exciting
i'm working from home and my husband is
also working from home
beautiful so you know i just found some
time and okay this is
yeah well that's great so i thank you so
much um
oh i really appreciate you know
uh what you do and uh i i don't have any
particular question but i'm wondering
if you have any question about like you
know what's going on in japan
oh i have so many questions kyoko it's
so great that you called in
here's what i want to know i know that
so many neighborhoods in japan
are known for these really small
restaurants you know eight seats 10
seats 12 seats
are they totally shut down because of
the virus or are they open
i lost you oh boy
yes yes please okay the small
restaurants the eight and ten seat
restaurants that tokyo and other parts
of japan are known for
have they been able to remain open
during the pandemic or have they had to
close
uh well they were open and then
currently we are um
under uh state of emergency once again
yeah they don't call it a lockdown just
a state of emergency just
requesting government requesting those
uh restaurants
to close at eight o'clock okay for
currently for four prefectures
prefectures are like a state yes united
states
so yeah four four big prefectures
including of course tokyo
and you know surrounding prefectures
they're they're close
they are requested to close at eight
o'clock
so you know those small restaurants as
you know yeah they are known to serve
alcohol and then the government thinks
it's the wrong
this is the risky situation where people
get together
right they stay longer they they tend to
drink a lot and then they talk aloud you
know
so they consider it's a very risky
situation and so they
but before eight before 8 pm k
if you have a 10 seat restaurant all 10
seats can be filled
uh yeah wow that seems dicey yeah
i know i know but the problem is that
the people are complaining that people
working at you know um you know after
the office hours if they want to eat
something before going home
right you know by the time they reach to
those small restaurants
they're all closed right they have to
rush in
maybe you know before eight o'clock you
know just they just pack into those
small restaurants
just before the closing time right and i
consider it's risky
and also they go to a convenience stores
there are tons of convenience stores in
japan which are open for 24 hours
so they rush there and then they get
something to eat
now i've heard that i've heard that the
sushi at the convenience stores isn't
bad
yeah it's uh sushi i don't know i never
bought sushi
okay um convenience store fair beauty is
quite good
that's fair that's fair is your husband
what we would call a salary man
oh yeah he's a typical salary man and
he's an
indian so he can even talk with you in
english
but he's from india he's from india but
he lives in japan
yes okay here for 17 years wow married
for
10 years yeah this is it now let me ask
you one other question
do you ever make a homemade miso soup
oh yeah when you make the miso soup do
you
use the fish flakes in making the dashi
uh yes um it's a combination usually we
use
bonito flakes and also you can
mix with the mushroom shiitake mushroom
really mushroom yes so there's anything
you know um induce what you call umami
you know that amino acid
yeah you can mix the vegetable based
broth and
so in other words you're making you're
making your dashi with the bonito flake
the kombu and shiitake mushroom
wow so you can yeah you can uh find any
other
other like dried fish also like
sardine or you know yeah that's a
revelation kiyoko that you're that's
that's stunning
and and then if you are good then you
should if you're a good housewife or
some somebody
who are into cooking you're supposed to
make your own
broth but you know because uh now that's
interesting is it
is it considered culturally um is it
considered
not masculine for the man to make the
miso soup in japan
well you know um it's changing you know
nowadays the guys of course i mean you
can see on the youtube even
like uh um you know people even men
open those cooking channels and then
right it is it is really
becoming known but again you know if you
talk about my
father's generation my father never
cooked anything except
maybe sunny side up interesting
interesting
well kyoko it's all it's all fascinating
you're really blowing my mind here i'm
curious where did you learn such great
english
oh thank you oh well no i
i haven't lived abroad but i'm working
as an interpreter now i really love
english and then you know since i was
kid
i tried to get any you know possible
chance to
listen to english and then you know um
finding a channel like you is also one
of my
favorite activities and i was so excited
when i found you
and even though oh i don't really um
i don't really care about japanese
politics but i'm interested in american
politics so yeah i was very happy to
find you
well i really appreciate the call yeah
continue yeah thank you i continue to
support you as much as i can so
really exciting do you um last question
have you taken up a position yet
uh on the toontoon channel and whether
he should continue doing thai cooking or
go japanese
well i love thai cooking so because i am
not stick to a japanese cooking
and my husband also he's not into any
indian cooking or whatever
whatever we we just love eating so
okay i yeah i go out to eat you know
even
during the lockdown i mean a state of
emergency yeah
we continue to eat like you know on
weekends but
of course um after taking all the
precautionary measures so well kyoko
you've said it all you are our first
japanese caller and our best japanese
caller and i hope to hear from you again
yes sure thank you so much david and uh
please uh
take care of yourself all right you too
uh
wow i mean it's a perfect phone call
guys
it's i don't know i we've now i don't
know that we've had anything like it
um we are going to have to clip that and
publish that during our uh vacation
absolutely perfect phone call i predict
no investigations
as a result of that i want to say thanks
to dimitri
zas for signing up at joinedpakman.com
also
scott hack who are new members 126 and
127
and then also thanks to robin your
rhubarb
and sv films for dropping two
subscriptions
via twitch we are taking calls via
discord
i don't know i mean whoever has to go
after kyoko
you know you're you're in a tough spot
it's gonna be hard to do justice to that
um let's go maybe to uh
let's go to matt from arizona known at
one point as covet hell
[Music]
oh they're speaking spanish yes someone
ate meatballs and soup it sounds like
one of your kids
uh yeah that's actually in the
background that's good is it is that is
that a good outcome when they've had the
meatballs
uh you know what's funny i actually
don't speak spanish but my
you didn't even know what was being said
yeah that's incredible
yeah um so
i i apologize i i walked out just right
now no no problem
um yeah i listened to the whole speech
and everything and just during the whole
time
i was uh tuning in onto a different um
media outlet and you just see so many
trump supporters just attacking them
for like like they're not even listening
to the conf
to the to the to the um
you know the speech right and
and i just want to like i've wasted a
lot of time
trying to convince trying to talk to him
trying to reason
and i just want to basically put it out
there people we need to stop
let's just move forward these people are
not worth our time
oh you're saying abandon these people
they're beyond our reach
yeah i mean at this point you know yeah
they've fallen for it they
they've drank the kool-aid they've done
everything that they could to just
denounce
reason yep and you know so
it's almost like we have to start
focusing on the next generation their
kids you know but
but i don't think anybody is a lost
cause the problem is
like what level of nasty programming is
is feasible
that's true i don't know i mean you know
uh i'm just saying like i see a lot of
people on the left engaging with these
people and it goes nowhere
it goes nowhere it goes nowhere you you
waste your time you could do something
much more productive
go go for a jog that's more productive
than talking
i i don't disagree with you at the
individual level i mean i do think that
there are ways
at the mass level to try to reach large
swaths of people and pick off some of
them and bring them over
but at the individual level it's like
unless you you really to change
someone's mind you really have to
develop like a deeper relationship with
them where they start to consider the
things you're saying in a different way
and that can take months and it's like
that's fine but how many people can you
do that with
yeah at a massive i could see that
individually
i mean i've never changed anybody's mind
right i know that i've wasted my time
doing it
well maybe you're not that good at it
you have to account maybe someone else
is better i don't know
yeah that's true no but in all
seriousness i mean it's like it's very
hard for anybody to do
yeah no uh but i apologize for my lack
of uh
under you know spanish no problem now
speaking of arizona though are is it
okay there i have a lot of friends there
and they say it's pretty pretty
wacky um
it depends where you live honestly i
live um
out of the city out of phoenix i live
in a town called santan valley okay and
uh
honestly everywhere i go everyone's
wearing a mask oh is that right okay
yeah and they enforce it too that's good
with someone here they'll say hey you
got a mask no okay we'll get out
you know interesting so not everywhere
is going nuts there
not everywhere but in the major parts
especially um
more more red districts you'll you'll
see it
and you've got any anti-vaxxers you're
in touch with oh yeah
and what what reason do they give for
not getting it
that it was it was made too soon if if
they can't
make the cure for cancer then why can
why can why are they able to uh
make the vaccine for so they don't even
understand the difference between like
communicable disease and cancer as a
concept it sounds like
yeah they uh and they and they can't be
reasoned with either no i just don't
trust it i can't
uh i wanna i wanna wait till other
people do it and then i can see
well other people have done it in the
millions now right
but what do you need a billion people to
do i mean you know you can always uh you
can always say you need to wait more
yeah i do want to say that i um
i'm trying to get in for a pfizer
vaccine or maybe even
moderna i don't want to go i don't want
to go with j j
so i'm going to push back on that here's
the thing so why don't you want the j
just the efficacy here's the thing
here's the thing matt
it is increasingly appearing as though
you know how the pfizer and moderna were
tested last year
and the jnj was tested a little more
recently yeah
the jnj was tested against some of these
tougher variants
so had you tested the pfizer and moderna
vaccines
on the same people it's quite possible
that the efficacy would have been
similar we don't know that for sure
but it appears that that very well may
be the case and they're all
almost 100 effective at preventing
sirius covid so i would get whichever
one you can get
that makes sense i didn't think of that
and i haven't seen anything of this so
yeah i really appreciate your
input on that all right matt from
arizona thanks for the call
thanks dave all right there we go uh
matt a lot of things on people's minds
here
let me say a quick thank you to
um uncle damian and
in a pug's eye who signed up
via twitch and that is 1560
puts us at a total of 131
for the night which is strong very very
strong
um let's go next to
oh you know who's with us actually i
need to talk to her
it's ciara from from spain
hey hi i i i wanted to
maybe contribute with a downer
i was very jealous of your new president
in his speech
we were kind of on par with how we were
dealing with the virus in spain in the
united states
way ahead of us now well here's what i
want to know because
i'm i'm looking very strongly
at going to spain in late july
or early august but there's a question
as to whether i'll be allowed to get in
like my my sister and my stepmom
have spanish citizenship so they can
they can get in any time
i'd like to go but does it look like
they will have like a vaccine exemption
in spain anytime soon
you would um i would say
yes and i would say just for a simple
reason
the our local the president of the
community of madrid is letting everybody
in
oh boy kiara you're you i don't know
what's going on with your phone are we
on speaker tell me we're not on speaker
no i'm wearing my earphones oh it's
quite weaponized
i'm so sorry i don't know what's wrong
okay uh you were saying
people are allowed into spain into
madrid
yeah madrid is full of french people at
the moment
oh right but americans americans aren't
allowed as far as i know
not yet but i have a feeling if the same
you know politics remain we will be
letting people in quite a bit
madrid is one of the few places in
europe where theaters remained open the
whole time
oh really and yeah they're just dancing
with the virus and
and that just seems like the way they're
going so i have a feeling we'll be more
open than most places
sooner okay all right so maybe i'll be
able to go yeah obviously only if it's
safe i'm going to be going by the
guidelines
yeah i just didn't require a pcr or
a vaccine of course yeah but otherwise i
think you would be allowed
beautiful um i wanted to ask you though
um i i got covered
before the knockdowns um
and we i i think in a choir we all got
covered
um and i work at a theater actually
and i was wondering if you are taking
into account or
your presidential guidance taking talk
of my president i'm half american
um the the effects
the economic effects of all the people
with long growing which i am a victim of
as well
on getting back to work and getting
getting back to normalcy they say about
maybe five ten percent i guess it's more
than five uh
of infected people even if they're not
serious cases get long covered and i
a year on i still suffer from
a lot of problems and i'm able to go
back to work because all i do is sing
but
if right well i'm sorry to hear that
you're experiencing that
when you say is it being taken into
account i mean i guess the answer is yes
and no you know we're aware that that
this
that long covet is a thing uh it
fortunately affects a small percentage
of the people who got the virus so you
know it's
it i don't know at the macroeconomic
level what the impact will be
but it is certainly an issue
yeah yeah and in our case in our choir
ten percent of us have long coded
wow um and that was a lot i guess the
first variant was more
prone to developing into long cover that
i don't know
but but uh it was amazing now i think
it's enough people it's true but i i
have a feeling like an image in spain
it's about hundreds of thousands of
people have known
i don't know how they're going to get
back to work wow yeah that's gonna have
to be dealt with what are the symptoms
that tend to be
it's it's respiratory it's the sensation
that you can't breathe although your
lungs
has time yeah uh tachycardia brand
cardio sorts of heart
issues wow and it comes in waves so
like right now i have a good day that's
why i'm calling but i'm gonna have bad
days like i can't function
right wow that's terrible no i mean
i'm getting better it's super slow but i
have a feeling that it will eventually
get better
it just seems to be a thing of one to
three years instead of
three to six months well i don't think
we can say three years yet since it's
not been three years you
it's definitely more know once right the
original stars had his face
up to one to three years later maybe
something like that
i see i see i see well listen kiara i'm
sorry to hear that
do you stay up all night every night no
i'm actually moving in with my parents
because it's hard to take care of myself
and watch decisions and do normal things
and i need the extra help i see uh so
i'm in the middle of a move i have to
get up by the weekend and i'm just
staying up again
wow all right well listen i appreciate
you calling in
i'm sorry to hear that you're still not
all the way all the way better but let's
let's keep it going yes yes absolutely
and thank you so much for your show
it's a breath of fresh pressure thank
you i appreciate that there's kiara from
madrid spain
a big thank you to candice lee as well
as nature boy for signing up via twitch
prime
uh that puts us for the evening at a a
really great number of
let's talk to a few more people um
where do we want to go here there's a
lot i just i mean listen there's a lot
of people holding there's no way in hell
i'm getting to everybody who's holding
right now but
you know we'll talk to some people let's
go to david from scotland david you're
on the air
hello david how are you how are you i'm
i'm excellent can i
start by just thanking kyoko from japan
for such an amazingly
positive representation of your
international audience what a lovely
person she was
nothing short of a perfect phone call
right lovely
perfect lovely yeah anyone asks always
perfect
and i would like to ask your thoughts as
an
immigrant if you don't mind me asking
about
how cultures can interact yes
in scotland we have a lot of americans
who come over here
to research their roots and we love it
we really really want to engage with the
world anyone that wants to come over
here we're happy to have you
beautiful however i've noticed that a
lot of americans that do come over here
are slightly jarred by our politics a
lot of them are surprised by
um how in their words socialistic we are
oh see so here's the thing this would be
in any country in
any country there are so many clueless
americans it's very common that
americans show
up somewhere and they have no idea
what's going on and they look shocked
that's
that's not unique to scotland yes
yes i entirely agree with you except
that the genus of these tourists are
that they are incredibly well involved
they are incredibly well educated
they know documentary history they know
scott's law that they can rely on to do
their research they know where they want
to go
they know who they want to talk to like
often these people
are um well for one wealthy enough to be
able to come to scotland
but also come to scotland with an intent
behind it
i see what surprises me
is that when they do they've done all
this research
other than they've never researched how
scotland will see them
right well that is very american
to say i'm gonna go wherever and i don't
care how they see me
you should see the things i've seen in
france my friend
i i remember um a few years ago
i was in washington dc i met a few
americans
and an event for scots abroad yeah
and i used to smoke at the time i pulled
out a cigarette packet
from europe that i don't know if you
know this but in
europe all of our cigarette packets have
warnings on them yes
same in the u.s yeah but like very
graphic warnings yeah right right the
pic you have like pictures of black
tongues and stuff there
yeah like like the whole shebang like
please don't smoke all that stuff
yeah i've since given up smoking but at
the time i pulled out this packet and
somebody made a comment to me like like
in
in this event that i didn't know
y'all were that nazi over
that's weird yeah that's i mean i'd have
to talk to that person but that sounds
odd
for sure for sure the the the point i'm
trying to get to is it took me a year to
try to
just like break down that conversation
in my head
and that was just one conversation how
many
cultural barriers are we
hello
hello uh sorry sorry i i lost you there
for a second how many cultural barriers
are we
[Music]
not even discussing that we just take
for granted
i think many i think many many many many
david
thank you very much for your thoughts
hey listen david before you go what do
you
what do you call the category of drinks
that includes coca-cola sprite fanta etc
uh for us it's just like well it depends
if you're on the west
coast of scotland you call it jeg jag
jeg j e j
jegs okay we can't pronounce your
letters like jeg
as in like j-e-g got it on the east
coast of scotland we would just call it
like juice
hello we would just call it juice
on the east coast you would call it just
jus like the spanish word for juice
well but yes but that's a joke by the
way i'm not that's it's hugo i know that
spell spell it one more time for me at j
u i c e juice g
u i c e j you oh juice
juice like here okay you call
soda juice okay and then what do you
call what do you call
juice well we call it juice
so how do you distinguish soda versus
juice
well we do it through interpretive dance
no um
we just like a lot of scots is built on
uh intonation and tone rather than the
words that you say
so it's like oh can i get a jeg as
opposed to oh can i get a jig
those mean different things really and
one means juice and one means soda
yeah that is shocking
that is shocking okay all right david
i'm gonna i'm gonna you know chew on
that a bit i appreciate the call
and thank you very much for putting up
with my bad signal my
my pleasure all right there we go david
from scotland wow
uh let's go to a us-based caller since
we are a us-based show
let's go to uh how about
we could go to cletus but that that
seems like let's check it out
cletus here on the air
yes just barely cletus know why
i was having a hard time hearing you is
that better it's marginally better hold
on oh i know hold on let's see
try it again hello yeah that's a little
better i've got you pumped up
okay hey i've been wanting to get a hold
of you do you
actually not know what those nonsense
messages you get are which nonsense
messages
they just don't make any sense i've been
listening to your show and every once in
a while
i think somebody will get banned or
something because they're just
they it just sounds like random words
yesterday there was one example of that
but i don't remember others
okay so anyway do you don't know what
that is no what is it
okay so on your cell phone
it's kind of like a game so you
let your phone suggest words
and then you just keep picking the
second word it suggests
that's not what it is because they're
the they're not like is the is the
let me ask you this cletus is the word y
k is that a word
oh was that in there would would your
phone suggest the word yk
i don't know yeah right so i don't think
that's what it is
oh okay well anyway that was just uh an
idea that i thought maybe what those
were hey where is your accent from are
you from alaska
oh my gosh i don't know i have an accent
but i'm from minnesota
oh minnesota okay it's that okay there
there's a there's a little bit of a uh
michelle bachman thing going on there i
got it
oh yeah yeah yeah i could see that yeah
so i already listened to your show this
year and
i absolutely love your content uh
and uh you're so wonderful to listen to
appreciate what you do
thank you cletus i appreciate that yep
all right take care you too there is
cletus
very amazing just got very american
hardcore american
um why don't we go to our caller from
uh let's go to casey from oklahoma city
whoa
did you just pop a soda i did not
oh i just heard a hiss that sounded like
i got you right popping a soda
no well i i don't mean to bring down the
show but
i live in oklahoma as you see that is
going to bring it just mentioning that
we'll bring it down
so my senators langford and hoff and
yeah
i just see like the biden speech tonight
and it's just
clear that there's like no interest in
even
viewing what someone might have to say
before disregarding it
and being so hyper partisan that i don't
i just
it's so frustrating and i know you're
very level-headed
and i i i respect you for that but it is
so damn frustrating
wait so what's your cut your comment is
that for people in your state
when biden says stuff like he said
tonight people just don't even they just
disregard it and they don't even care
what he's saying
well well that but more specifically
just
like the gop you know senators
the representatives they just they're so
partisan
oh yeah yeah yeah it's just so extremely
frustrating and i don't know
i i get so angry about it
uh because it's just so blatant that
it's partisan
i agree no attempt to even look at what
is being said or can
like if you could be a normal person and
hear biden tonight and just go
yeah that's some that's empowering
uplifting and there's some hope and
we're getting stuff done but you can't
because it's blue right now and um being
able to pass you know the
the different stimulus that was done
under trump with no problem yet when
when it's blue ink all sudden it's it's
the worst thing ever and no one can vote
for it
and to some degree there's this on both
sides but it's particularly bad right
now with this
obstructionist republican party right
well and even when you have the
popularity that you did of this last one
right it's like if you're not
representing your constituents you know
i might be a minority in oklahoma but
even republicans supported it
so yeah it's like who are you who are
you representing
hey what's the um what who are the
americans that are most stereotyped in
oklahoma is it like californians or new
yorkers bostonians what what is it like
that you guys stereotype
that's tough because i'm not in circles
to do that so much
i mean so a lot of my in-laws and family
they'll talk about
california you know california is
typically the one that they complain
about
okay and is it just like california
liberals and that type of thing
yeah okay got it all right
well i appreciate the call casey thank
you yeah and thanks for the
shout out to the uh wife and kids oh
that was you okay beautiful beautiful i
hope they're doing well
all right man okay talk to you later yep
there it is uh really hearing from a
wide wide swath of people right now and
there's people just
really all over it's crazy what's
happening why don't we try
there's just a lot of i'm trying to go
to someone new
hard to remember everybody who's new um
let's see here how about michael from
colorado michael from colorado you're on
there
hello can you hear me yes i can wow uh
awesome david i just had a sort of a
philosophical
kind of heavy question for you okay um
so it kind of is is leading off uh to
what casey just said
um will america always be a battle of
uh ideology ideologies politically
and how do you see uh america ultimately
turning out in
like 250 years you know i think that
it's it's
it's almost silly for me to answer
because
we can't even predict the next five
years and so
i don't want to pretend like i have any
special insight but like
economists are terrible at predicting
what the economy is going to do
technologists a hundred years ago were
mostly predicting things that
uh never happened and the things that
did happen they never predicted
i i just don't know i mean to be honest
i was actually
talking today uh with with my girlfriend
about what is more interesting to me the
idea of going back in time or forward in
time and for me
although it would be interesting to go
back in time to see whether history is
right or wrong about certain things
i'm much more interested in like what
what does humanity look like 10 000
years into the future and so i
with 250 we might feel like we can
predict it and i still don't think we
can
with 10 000 it's it's like i think we
all know we have no idea what things
will be like and that seems more
interesting to me
but i mean it's almost like
conservatives and liberals are so
different that
it's almost like they should both just
have their own countries obviously
that's not practical but
well listen in 10 000 years maybe
they'll have their own planets
yeah okay well you turned it into ten
thousand years that works so definitely
yeah
all right well thank you i appreciate
you answering yeah sorry i don't have
any hot take on it
no no no worries um and then i just
wanted to kind of lead off with or
well sorry i'm nervous i'm kind of
you're doing great i wanted to end it
with some
some maybe positive news i don't know
there's lauren
uh beaubart uh billboards i guess
around town uh basically calling for her
resignation so that's kind of exciting
yeah i mean it won't happen but i would
love it
no no yeah of course uh it's just it's
just funny but okay thank you very much
david all right thanks uh michael from
colorado there dealing with lauren
beaubert and all of that stuff
all right guys that's gonna do it for
calls uh we have some beautiful phone
calls today i think we're gonna clip
and publish during our vacation the
japan
call and the scotland call those those
were particularly interesting
and maybe we will look at uh look at
some others as well
uh okay thanks for joining me everybody
uh very very much appreciated it's been
quite a stream
and we'll be back with everybody
tomorrow and then many more things going
on
remember follow on twitch
subscribe on youtube it's all free
and then you'll be notified next time i
go live alright see everybody soon
you